Is Thanos about to pull a Michael Myers and
come back for another film after his death?
According to a new report from We Got This
Covered, the Mad Titan made famous in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe by Josh Brolin could
be making a triumphant return in the next
MCU saga.
The outlet cites an anonymous source that
claims Thanos will rear his massive purple
head once again in the, quote, "upcoming Annihilation
storyline" of the MCU which hasn't been confirmed,
mind you.
There's also reportedly a possibility that
the intergalactic despot who died twice in
Avengers: Endgame once via beheading at the
hands of Thor…
"What did you do?"
"I went for the head."
… and later when Tony Stark used his own
take on the Infinity Gauntlet to snap past
Thanos out of existence will make a cameo
in The Eternals, popping up in sequences that
show him in his younger years.
This could kick off Thanos' big return to
the MCU, with a brief appearance in the Chloé
Zhao -directed feature, due out on November
6, 2020, leading into a more prominent presence
in films that will tell the Annihilation story
and introduce the MCU to the villain named
Annihilus.
"Forward!
And attack!
Destroy anything in your path!"
We Got This Covered expressed confidence in
its source and the information they have provided,
as the person or people claiming that Thanos'
return is on the horizon is the same source
that indicated Taskmaster would be the villain
in the forthcoming Black Widow movie.
Based on the source's track record, one could
easily be convinced that Thanos is coming
back to the MCU.
Rumors about Annihilus potentially joining
the Marvel movie world have swirled for ages
- does this mean that Marvel will actually
tell the Annihilation comics storyline in
the future and that Thanos will be a part
of it?
Written by Keith Giffen with editor Andy Schmidt
and a host of artists, Annihilation focuses
on many of the space-related characters in
the Marvel Universe as they face off with
Annihilus, an alien whose unquenched thirst
for conquest causes him to unleash the Annihilation
Wave onto the galaxy.
Annihilus is responsible for the attacks in
the storyline and Thanos, with the guidance
of villains Skreet and Mistress Death, initially
forms an alliance with him.
Eventually, though, Thanos decides to betray
Annihilus when he realizes he's planning to
wipe out all life in the universe.
Hmm… where have we heard that one before?
"I know what I must do.
I will shred this universe down to its last
atom."
Obviously, a lot went on in Annihilation,
and Thanos played an important part in the
action.
It makes sense that if Marvel truly is planning
to introduce Annihilus and adapt the Annihilation
storyline for the silver screen, then Thanos
would return for those films.
However, this all seems quite unlikely.
Sure, Thanos could return to the MCU.
Yes, Marvel can bring him back in Eternals
flashbacks, or a storyline set before the
events of Avengers: Infinity War and Avengers:
Endgame.
And while the opportunity is certainly there,
the foundation for this idea is flimsy at
best.
It's not a done deal that Thanos will actually
cameo in The Eternals, as We Got This Covered's
source simply said it's a "possibility."
Even if he does appear in the film, which
is plausible considering he is an Eternal
himself, there's no guarantee that he'll show
up in any other Marvel movie thereafter.
Additionally, we know what Marvel has planned
for its Phase 4 films, and it seems that no
movie in that phase apart from The Eternals
will allow for Thanos to return in any noteworthy
capacity, if at all.
Even when Phase 5 inevitably rolls around.
there might not be room for movies solely
focused on the Annihilation storyline, with
the planned sequels to Black Panther and Captain
Marvel, Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3, and
possible X-Men and Fantastic Four projects
and don't forget about Blade!
That phase will probably launch movies in
2022 and 2023 to follow up the Phase 4 films
releasing in 2020 and 2021, meaning Phase
6 will likely play out in 2024 and 2025.
By that point, several years after his potential
cameo in The Eternals, would anyone really
care about seeing Thanos making a legitimate
return to the MCU?
Maybe, but that's a long way off.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.